Hey everybody! Rocco T. Mole here
to wish you a Happy Mole Day
from all of us at Khan Academy!
Yes, moles!
The chemistry concept, not the critter.
Now, in case you’ve been living under a rock (like me)
a mole is another name for Avogadro’s number
which is (approximately) 6.022 times 10 to the 23rd.
Kinda like how a “dozen” is another name for 12.
So why do we need a name for such a big number?!
Well, we could write it like this: 602,214,129,000,000,000,000,000
(Thank you)
But that would take a while!
Moles make counting easier for chemists,
particularly when talking about atoms or molecules.
So for the number of molecules in a cup of water,
you could write an 8 with 24 zeros after it...
OR you could just call it 13 moles of water instead!
(Thank you Yuki)
Isn't that easier?
Now, the moral of this story is: moles are the best!
And if you want to learn more about chemistry,
or anything, really, head to our website: khanacademy.org
That's Khan as in Ghenghis, no relation; and Academy, as in academy.
Happy Mole Day everyone!
You can learn anything!
Are we still–we're not recording, right?